[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
welcome
everybody I am so excited I hope you're
excited too I thought every day we have
a two-time guest on the podcast but we
did 112 Time Podcast guest and that's Dr
Moya mcteer who is now a doctor a real
honest to goodness doctor something that
uh you might not have guessed as you
were growing up with your story that we
talked about in the first time you were
on the podcast and that episode is
called folklorist to the Stars uh and
we'll talk briefly about that but I want
to introduce you uh to all to those of
you who may not be familiar our audience
has expanded like the Galaxy no the
Galaxy's not expanding uh but like the
universe the universe yes yeah in the
two years exactly since uh moyan was on
she was a she was a humble grad student
and now she's a renowned
um scientist PhD graduate of the
Columbia University in the city of New
York City I think is the full name of it
right you have to read the full thing
legally uh
who I went to Brown University and brown
universities in Rhode Island but that's
not the name of the state the name of
the state is
Rhode Island and Providence plantations
um so that I didn't know that the
longest name of any state of the
probably got rid of plantations that's
not that's active anymore uh but you're
on today because of this wonderful book
The Milky Way and autobiography of our
galaxy this book is so great that the
most famous the best cosmologist in the
world gave an encomium on the back and
yes of course Sean Carroll and Stefan
Alexander and chonda Prescott Weinstein
all friends of the show and in one way
or another Paul Sutter rhymes with
butter I'll never make that mistake
again
um so Sean called it an entertaining
introduction to some of the most
profound features of our astrophysical
neighborhood
I'm trying to call it an exciting romp
through the universe and Stefan
Alexander said out of this world work of
Genius wow it's better than he said in
my two books uh no I was impressed when
I saw that and lastly your humble host
uh Brian Keating said a deliciously
hilarious and irresistible romp
shimmering with astrophysical facts
Cutting Edge observation mcteer pens the
autobiography that our galaxy deserves
and Moya this is a phenomenal
accomplishment first of all uh I hate it
when uh when you have a comedian go on
Stephen Colbert and then Colbert says
why are you so funny what makes you so
funny because guaranteed the next thing
they're going to say is hilariously
unfunny but you have this incredible wit
and the galaxy has such a sharp tongue
uh where did this come from where where
did this idea first of all come from and
I know I'll actually start with what
we're never supposed to do what we
couldn't do last time because you didn't
have a book of this caliber you had
books of High Caliber but and works but
this is a published by hashat group and
Grand Central publishing but what I like
to do is Judge books by their covers
because what else are you going to do
right so what's that that's the
information you have first exactly right
it's it's it's the first you know prior
information so Moya please tell us what
is the meaning of the cover design and
the subtitle of this wonderful new book
yes so this cover I I didn't design it
they had someone at the publisher do it
and they sent me two options originally
um and when I saw this cover which is
like a pink
nebula behind the words the Milky Way I
was just in love and I was like that one
it has to be that one
um it originally did not have the
Andromeda constellation on it and I
asked them to add it in because you have
a book you're attached to it aren't you
aren't you a little bit attached yet
well the the Milky Way is certainly
attached to the Andromeda galaxy and I
just wanted to bring in that piece of
romance to the book but it's called an
autobiography of our galaxy because it
is written from the perspective of the
Milky Way galaxy telling its own story
from its birth that's in air quotes all
the way to its eventual demise which
would be the end of the universe
right and uh but as an autobiography
what gave you that idea because that is
such a unique uh I I I've never you know
read uh I mean there's books of folklore
and kind of descriptions as you go
through and we'll talk about in this
conversation but the idea for an
autobiography of what we thought of
until now as an inanimate object where
did that how did that inspiration strike
you
really I think it came from a place of
insecurity
security that it came from this place
where I was very excited to get a deal
to write a book but I didn't want to
just put something out there that other
people had done and I was looking at
books by by people like you by people
like Stefan Alexander and I was like who
am I to add my voice like what what can
I really add that is new not much uh but
the Milky Way can add a lot
um and I thought that it would just be a
fun way to learn about this and maybe a
less intimidating
narrator than than a person like you or
or Dr Alexander yeah yeah well it's
phenomenally successful and uh and it's
one of those books that you know I think
the real encomium I want to give is it's
the book I wish I could have written uh
because actually there are similarities
in our books and that um dust and gas
play a huge role in the Milky Way and
also in your book and of course the dust
and gas are the villains of my first
book losing the Nobel Prize which is all
about how dust obscured our glimpse of
the birth of the universe but what's so
fascinating about this book is that you
really give an astrophysicist
um I don't want to say I but but the
Insight of a of a professional but you
do it in such a ways to be accessible
without I hate these two words dumbed
down uh you react when someone says can
you dumb it down you're such a super
uber genius can you dumb it down for me
how do you react to that you may not
feel the same way as me no I think I do
I really hate it because just because
someone doesn't know about the expansion
of the universe or they don't know these
cosmological facts that doesn't mean
they're dumb that just means they
haven't heard them before they haven't
learned it everyone has to learn
something for the first time at some
point right so we don't have to dumb it
down we just have to translate it to
what they already know
exactly and you do it in such an
inviting accessible way that I think it
will appeal you know usually the worst
advice you can give to an author is you
know they ask well who is it for and you
say well make it for everybody no no
that'll be nobody exciting you know
except for your immediate family but
this really is accessible and and the
way that you do and kind of like start
off or or the pitch for the book is you
know it All Began 13 billion years ago
in clouds of gas scattered throughout
the universe's primordial plasma just
could not keep their metaphorical hands
off of each other they should come to
the gravitational attraction in the
Galaxy we knew it was born since then so
this is kind of steamy we're keeping
PG-13 you know my audience is Young
um and uh they name in the purpose
Galactic archaeologists have worked to
determine its true age which is rude
according to miss how do you think of
the Milky Way do you think of it as a
gender or no no
um and and it says several times I'm
using the pronoun it because it says
several times that galaxies don't care
about gender they don't have any of our
fleshy bits they don't have any of our
hormones like they don't they don't give
a crap so it is genderless
and I always like to ask you know uh
from your perspective after you uh
having uh you know written written this
book in many works of of folklore
um you learn something when you're doing
it or is it something that you know you
you had so much knowledge being a PhD at
one of the top universities in the
Galaxy
um you know that you have this insight
for and so you didn't really learn
anything but you learned you know you
packaged it or did you learn something
were there new facts about the Galaxy
astrophysics cosmology black holes what
did you learn if anything
yeah I learned a lot for this book I the
outline was was stuff that I already
knew I've taken cosmology classes I've
taken Galactic Evolution classes so I
knew most of it but some of the details
in both the science and the folklore
were new to me
um the the chapter near the end where I
I start talking about Quantum field
Theory and how uh because I had to
explain Quantum field Theory and uh what
the Higgs boson is to explain that
potential ultimate fate of the Universe
um so I I had to learn that I have never
taken a Quantum class and that was
really fun actually
um and then some of the the folklore I
am not very strong on my East Asian
folklore and the most of the
Scandinavian like northern European
folklore that I know is Norse and
Germanic so I got to read up on some
Finnish myths
um and some like Eastern European uh
like Serbian myths which was really fun
I love the illustrations
um and there's so many uh they're so
Whimsical in many ways but they're also
Technical and they have a lot of uh I
always say red meat but there's a lot of
vegans that listen so I'm going to say
some white tofu is that okay uh yeah
yeah some Jackfruit from Jackfruit
whatever you need but then that's all
I'm gluten-free I don't want to deal
with it uh but some of the things and
they're really evocative and actually
took me back to my last Voyage down to
uh Chile
um you know South Pole there's not so
many indigenous people that live there
there's some indigenous penguins that
live on the continent but besides that
so you'll get an exposure literally
figuratively to you know incredible
astronomical information but condense in
a way that anybody can understand it and
again it's a book I wish not only that I
could have written but but that I could
have read as a you know teenager when I
was just getting my first little
telescope uh not far from New York City
and and looking up and and really just
like looking at it's so over
overwhelming and what I like about this
book is that it uses this this
metaphorical vehicle of of the Galaxy as
the protagonist in this hero's journey
our heroine's journey or you know
androgynous journey
and what's so fun about it is um is that
you don't you take on the whole universe
but it's it's subtle it sneaks up on you
was that by Design in other words you're
using your discretizing the universe
into a Galaxy as the fundamental unit
our home Galaxy as a particular example
but you're teaching about everything
from Quantum fields to black holes to
exoplanets to Dustin was that
intentional or did that emerge during
the course of the writing of the book
absolutely intentional
um one of the reasons I chose to write
it from this perspective was because
that
when I think about the Universe I
picture it as a collection of galaxies
and and I also know that galaxies are
collections of stars which are
collections of atoms but I I like what
you said that galaxies are kind of like
the base unit
um and and as a Galaxy
it's it's the midpoint it can see these
small human scales it can watch us and
it can kind of understand what we're
like but it also understands the
universal skills and I I thought that
the Milky Way would be a nice translator
for us to get to thinking on those
larger than us scales that we need to
think from we need to think from that
perspective if we're ever going to
overcome all of our all of our human
squabbles that we have that's right and
you take the grand picture I found it
very stoic I had on Ryan holiday uh last
year who's a famous stoic author wrote
you know the obstacle is the way and
many other books on stoicism and you
know it's kind of uh it kind of has
these features of stoicism there's this
concept of Memento Mori you know know
that you're going to die you know
contemplating that uh and no but know
that you're going to live I always add
on to it and I wanted to to ask you if
that narrative concede in a good way is
born of your biography so I do want to
read your biography and in particular
the first sentence of your biography
which your publisher kindly sent me Dr
Moya mctear is an astrophysicist
folklorist and science Communicator
based in New York City after graduating
from Harvard that's in Massachusetts I
think yeah maybe you've heard of it
I don't know if Brown and now I know
it's Colombia in the ivy league as the
first person in the school's history to
study both astronomy and mythology Moy
earned her PhD in ashford's Columbia
University she was selected as an NSF uh
Foundation research fellow she has
consulted with companies like Disney and
PBS on their fictional World Health
design exhibits in the New York Hall of
Science and given hundreds of talks
about science around the globe including
features on MSNBC NPR now this news
when I wanted to drill down on is you
know to alleviate my uh my Jewish
neuroses that I couldn't have written
this because I know nothing about
folklore other than what you taught me
two years ago so in other words did your
training in folklore which is so unique
did that you know is that imbued
throughout this book in other words
could no one besides you have written
this book essentially what vehicles if
any come from folklore training
um I think someone like to Rita Holbrook
could have written this book
um maybe someone in the past like Owen
Gingrich could have written this book
there are archaeo astronomers around uh
so I don't think I have a 100 unique
perspective but yeah there aren't many
people who could have written this
because I really did want the folklore
to be a through line I see folklore as
an and maybe I've said this in our last
interview I see it as an early attempt
at science it was humankind's way of
explaining the natural world around them
and they did it with like gods and and
magical creatures but at its root these
mythologies that people came up with
were based on their observation of the
world just like science is today so I
wanted people to learn from this book
that it's it's like a spectrum you know
it's it it started off as mythology and
then there there was philosophy and and
you had people in the 1600s talking
about The Ether of the universe and now
we we can talk about dust and dark
energy and dark matter
um in in more scientific terms but I
wanted people to make that connection
right yeah and what fascinates me is
that you do go on from the biggest
skills to the small scales or or the
opposite maybe in some sense when I
encountered you know I haven't had as
much you know any training of it as I
said but in the Chilean Atacama Desert
we do encounter at our Observatory site
what are called atticaminos These are
natives of the Atacama Desert
um distant relatives perhaps the Inca
civilization uh and the Atacama Desert
was huge it's you know a thousand miles
north of South and it's it's literally
the driest place on Earth half the time
but what was so fascinating to me and
maybe I'll fold in I was there in 2019
when there was a total eclipse of the
sun visible from Chile not from the
Atacama deserts uh northern part with
the Simon's observatories uh
nevertheless we have locals there that
were kind of talking about their
folklore and what was so fascinating to
me is the role not that the Milky Way's
luminous bits play in their mythology
but the dust the dark you know dust
clouds that kind of pervade the um the
night sky and in fact they have
constellations that are dark as I
learned
um actually writing my first book and
then meeting uh some of them throughout
the last 10 years or so in that they
have things that they believe the stars
are dead and effectively the or
inanimate like the river uh the Milky
Way is like depicted as a river an
offense to the protagonist of your book
no no that's okay the Milky Way is all
right with that
like the river is what gives us life
right so the Milky Way loves that in in
in this mythology and it's mentioned in
the book that the the dark
constellations are living animals that
feed or like drink from the from the
water of the Milky Way
I just love it because there's uh
there's there's one con there's one dust
constellation Dark Cloud constellation
uh called The Llama I think it is and
then there's a sub constellation called
the umbilicus of the Llama so imagine
like you go up to a bar in you know in
1300 you know A.D and you're you're
talking to some some some uh you know
hot member of your preferred uh target
audience and you say yeah what's your
sign and they say um I'm an umbilicus oh
wow okay that's that's wonderful I love
that if there's like an old Chilean
astrology uh the way we have astrology
um and horoscopes these days it'd be
like oh the umbilicus like you're really
good at making connections and like
nurturing people
have you ever been asked these questions
uh Moya like oh you're an astronomer
you're so smart
um I'm a Pisces you know can you oh
that's okay I get that all the time so
what how do you react to it I react by
telling them
um astrophysically speaking there is no
reason for that to be a thing
historically astrology was much more
practical it was about when will you
plant your crops and
um when will you know that the the
nutrition you rely on every year is
coming back I mean in a in Australia the
Aboriginal Australians used to look for
um a constellation that they said looked
like an emu to uh kind of coincide with
when the earth emus were laying their
eggs and they would eat those eggs
um so astrology used to be very
practical so I usually say I don't know
anything about astrology astronomy and
astrology are different things these
days so I am not the expert you're
looking for
I I used to say that too but but it
never dissuades people so now I decide
to have some fun with it oh you're a
Pisces that um that lump on your
backside that's cute I don't want to say
it
do you do you know your sign do you like
get into conversations with them about
that
I do but I once had some fun with it so
I'm a I'm a Virgo but I went out with my
um my soon-to-be wife on a date many
many years ago and we encountered you
know someone on the street and and uh
and they were like oh I'll tell your
horoscope or whatever and I said okay
yeah I'm um I'm a Pisces
and they said oh well that's great and
and and uh here's what's gonna happen to
you and you know the IRS is going to be
con whatever they said and then I said I
just want to double check Pisces are the
ones that are born in in September right
I said no no that's Virgo
the same things are gonna happen to you
like it doesn't matter it didn't make
any difference and and so anyway so now
I decide to do that so there's so many
things we can talk about I mean one
thing that I get
uh now is that I get introduced you know
I'm a cosmologist and then I have to say
despite the appearance you know I don't
do hair and nails but in the case of
cosmology comes from Cosmos which is
another Greek word which means beauty or
face and one of the beautiful things of
this book is that you're portraying the
uh the visceral sensations of how people
reacted
um you know to not just the original
kind of you know indigenous cultures or
whatever but how people reacting to
Modern scientific facts so what did you
um what's the most fascinating I mean if
you have to pick I mean it's like
picking your favorite kid if you have
multiple kids right although I I would
say to my mom who's your favorite
there's four four of us Brothers I
should say that's like asking me to
choose my left hand or my right hand I
said Mom you understand yeah like you
have a favorite hand let's be real it's
me it's me
um your favorite aspect
is your is there a favorite aspect of
your favorite Galaxy or you know are all
nooks and crannies equally delightful my
favorite physical part of a galaxy
I mean I I gotta say the Bulge I for for
a Milky Way Type Galaxy a barred spiral
galaxy that has a central bulge in the
middle I think that the bulges where the
most exciting stuff happens and I am
totally biased because that's where I
did most of my PhD research but uh
that's where you get a dense enough
collection of stars that stars can
interact gravitationally fairly often uh
that's where you know if you're
imagining a Sci-Fi Universe where
there's this Federation of connected
star systems the bulges where that would
do really well because it's so easy to
slingshot yourself from one system to
another like I I would love to think
that in the Bulge of some galaxy
somewhere there's like a an alien subway
system of just getting slingshoted from
Once one system to another uh but the
but this the spiral arms are very pretty
I'll say that but for me it's the Bulger
what about you yeah
well I think them oh what's what so
fascinates me is the you know are the
kind of the dusty bits the the parts
that are both not only critical to the
formation of the planets uh and
eventually trickling down into the
material that uh our parents and mother
ate to to nourish us while we were being
gestated inside of her not not for
billions of years but
um and we actually have the same
material the iron that flows through our
blood you know is very similar to the
iron that is in this meteorite that I
keep on my
um I'll keep on my desk over here to
remind me that we are uh come from dust
and to dust we shall return so I would
say yeah dust is and it also provides a
cautionary tale that you know we kind of
Overlook uh the the dark parts of both
ourselves of society perhaps but but
also we want to not be obscured by by
things that are trying to keep us down
yeah peering through that will sometimes
give us the truest glimpse of Truth as
they say
yeah Gandhi said that um a person we go
through life trampling dust under our
feet but you should really be so humble
to think that a little piece of dust
could crush you and of course you know
that did happen uh into at least one
Cosmic experiment not too long ago
um so you know last time we talked we
talked a little bit about your research
I do want to go into a little bit more
detail on that uh you mentioned a little
bit about the Bold but specifically
inside the Bulge we talked a little bit
last time about exoplanets and they've
been in the news a lot um for obvious
reasons people suspect that there is
life outside our home planet I want to
ask you do you think I mean we don't
have evidence but do you think that
there is uh that we're alone I mean is
this great big empty Galaxy uh made for
us in a sense or is it just uh teeming
with life that we have yet to observe
our encounter if I'm being responsible I
have to say well the evidence does not
support it yet but but if I'm just being
me yes it would be such a waste of of
space I know I'm not the first person to
say that but it would be such a waste of
space if if we were the only ones here
and uh because I've studied exoplanets
and the habitability of those planets
and because as a folklorist my my
specialty is fictional World building I
can't help but think about the amazingly
diverse types of life that would form on
the equally diverse types of planets
that we have in in the universe the
planets range in size and the types of
stars that they orbit and the materials
that they're made of and the atmospheres
they have it's just there's so many
options
so I think yes probably
and besides the Andromeda galaxy which
you know kind of dominates what do you
make of these galaxies that are kind of
Rogue that don't really uh quite fit
into the mold of a typical Galaxy I'm
thinking of these galaxies that recently
may have been discovered that have no
dark matter in other words all their
gravitational force can be accounted by
the Luminous metal what do you think of
these or our satellite galaxies what do
you make of these little are they just
Hangers On you know on the retinue of
cosmic Paparazzi what do you make of
these satellite dwarf galaxies that
don't get much attention yeah the uh the
Milky Way certainly has strong feelings
about these dwarf galaxies uh in the
book
um I slash the Milky Way We we talk
mostly about Andromeda and the large and
small magellanic clouds who are are
Larry and Sammy respectively and we also
talk a lot about the triangulum Galaxy
which is a satellite around Andromeda
and yeah the Milky Way does kind of see
these these Dwarfs satellites as Hangers
On It complains that Larry the large
magellanic cloud is is lazy and really
bad at making decisions and it doesn't
make as much as many stars as it should
um but but they also have these these
gravitational interactions and you
hinted at it earlier when you were
reading the the synopsis that gravity
and gravitational attraction I I took
kind of literally in in this book so
that if you have a very strong
gravitational attraction it's almost
like a marriage or like a hookup or a
fling
um but even if it doesn't get to that
level that these galaxies are exchanging
material and that that makes them close
to each other
um
but these dark matter list galaxies I
think they're really interesting because
we we think
um that dark matter was really pivotal
in creating our galaxy that the the mass
of dark matter which was massive so it
could gravitationally attract things but
was cooler than the other matter around
it helped the material early on in the
universe Clump to form these Mass
Pockets that eventually turned into
galaxies so I think it's just so
interesting that there are some that
don't have much dark matter that we can
see
all right what's your what's the biggest
misconception about our galaxy or other
galaxies that you've encountered uh uh
in your career that everything is still
I have been shocked Lately by how many
people think that that
things in space are still and I think
that it it comes from uh we talk about
zero gravity existing in space
um I I think that that's a mistake that
we've made because there's gravity
everywhere in space and that gravity
makes everything move so I love telling
people about how the the sun moves
around the the Galaxy it's something
like 500 000 miles an hour I love
talking about how the Milky Way and
Andromeda are moving towards each other
um at something like a hundred
kilometers per second it's really fast
um so I yeah we are moving all the time
that's that's a big misconception
yeah yeah I often get this uh question
that presupposes knowledge about the
Galaxy that's wrong so people say
because all the matter in the Milky Way
is rotating around the black hole you
know it's kind of keeping us all
together
um let's talk about black holes they
feature prominently oh yes they do uh
what is the Milky Way's relationship
with the black hole that's a star we've
had on a chef dolman recently in the
most recent announcement of the the
Imaging of our own galaxies Event
Horizon
um talk about the black hole what what
does the black hole mean to the Milky
Way uh how does it react uh to uh so
much attention going to it okay first of
all I was so upset about the timing of
that event horizon telescope image like
you couldn't have put this out it was
like six months earlier because it felt
like that image came out just a few
weeks after I submitted the final copy
of the book and I was like Ugh too bad
but uh in this book
the Milky Way has a very strong
relationship with this supermassive
black hole sag a star which the Milky
Way calls Sarge
um and there's a joke in the book about
how the name sarge is not derived from
Sagittarius A star it's actually a much
older name derived from an old Galactic
language that means something like Duty
heads it's just like a very childish
insult that the Milky Way is giving its
black hole because in this book black
holes are the physical manifestation of
a Galaxy's essentially mental health
struggles
um and that's because I was writing this
book throughout a pandemic where I was
personally dealing with some of the
worst mental health issues that I've
ever had and I know that a lot of other
people were dealing with the same
so that's that's what the the black hole
represents and throughout the book The
Milky Way has to reckon with its mental
health struggles and figure out how to
not let Sarge consume the Milky Way
because we see examples out in space of
black holes that get so massive
um they get so hot they have such strong
feedback wins that they actually quench
the star formation in their home
galaxies essentially killing their
galaxies
um so there was this this tension in the
book where Sarge could kill the Milky
Way but the Milky Way had to figure out
how to not let that happen
um I wonder if we get pivot design you
said about the mental health issues I
know that you you know in our first
conversation we talked a little bit
about that we talked about
um you know what it's like to be a
graduate student uh how challenging that
was and how at that time even you
weren't planning to necessarily remain
in the field of you know a astronomical
you know kind of pecking order that I
call the academic Hunger Games you know
post-doc Junior faculty multiple
postdocs multiple faculty tenure track
you know uh Etc
um did anything of that play a role uh
because I know like you you when did you
defend you defended in 2010 yeah April
2021
okay so it was in the middle of the
pandemic but even before that you would
talk candidly about some of the
struggles that you just referred to I
wonder for those that haven't watched
the first episode but we'll consume that
right after this episode
um can you recapitulate a little bit
about that what is it like being a
student I've had on five or so students
actually I've had on you know four or
five students of color that are graduate
students and and some that are obviously
you know Advanced faculty you know
distinguished professors but I want to
ask you know is what what were those
struggles and and what advice would you
give to somebody you know who just
doesn't see the light at the end of the
tunnel whether that could be a pandemic
or grad school's taken six and a half
seven years or whatever my students at
nine years
seriously what was what were the
struggles and what advice do you have
for people going through that yeah so
grad school was very tough for me it was
not the only thing that contributed to
my mental health state but it was a big
factor uh especially during the pandemic
um I would say that as when you're a
grad student you spend part of your time
doing research early on in grad school
you spend a lot of time taking classes
and your your status in graduate school
is kind of dependent on your advisor and
the the chair and the people who make
decisions in your department and that in
itself is really difficult so grad
students don't get paid well most grad
students don't make a wage that allows
them to live in the area where they need
to to get to the grad school uh grad
school and Academia in general it has
this
opaque hierarchical structure there's
the grad there's you know like undergrad
students and then grad students and
postdocs and and multiple levels of
professors that you just mentioned
um and there is that hierarchical
structure but it's not always clear
how that structure is arranged and who
has what privileges in their positions
um so as a grad student you kind of are
at the mercy of
anyone else who is higher than you on
that ladder and uh there's also the the
added difficulty of Academia being
a difficult place to get jobs right now
there's no retirement age in Academia so
we are graduating more people with phds
but there aren't enough slots for them
to work in there aren't enough uh
careers for them to have if they want to
stick within Academia so that was that
was really hard for me
um I would say for advice to anyone who
is going through that one I know it's
difficult but try not to compare
yourself to other people who cares if
it's taking you six or seven or eight
years my mom uh had she got pregnant
with me and had me when she was in her
PhD program it took her 15 years to
finish her PhD so like don't don't
compare yourself to other people because
you don't know what type of Journey
they're on you don't know where they
started and you don't know what
obstacles are in their way they don't
know what Journey you're on you don't
know what Journey you're on you don't
know what's coming next so so try not to
compare yourself and try not to think of
where you should be because there is no
place where you should be right now
except for Where You Are
all right that's great yeah I mean I I
always you know I'm reluctant to give
advice but um yeah because everyone has
to go through Journeys together and
we'll in a few minutes go through you
know advice to your former self not
necessarily as a grad student could be a
as a young person if I remember
correctly your mother also wanted to
burden you with one of the most
challenging names there could possibly
right um but it wasn't spelled the same
way as my name as uh Brian right right I
think um
but homonymously
um but yeah I mean I hate it when people
give ideas you know like oh what should
you do uh I don't know what what's worse
when someone says you know gives you
advice from this you know like I know
everything or when they say my best
advice is just keep doing what you're
doing that's not it's not advice it's
not satisfying at all I think in some
ways I'd rather you just say nothing
because both of those pieces of advice
kind of suck yeah exactly right question
what does a say nothing
um so I want to talk about like a
research because now you are you know
you're I see you on TV I see you on Tick
Tock now you're trying to like get me
into Tick Tock I don't even know what
dominoes
I have not stopped thinking about that
review since I read it
so we'll put a link to all of your
social stuff people can uh can can know
what we're talking about but that was
great it inspired me that to like start
a tick tock account
um
so when when when you're assessing where
your career is now
um are you you know feeling like you
want to get back to the folklore side
you want to go more into the Outreach if
you want to become a pundit the science
Communicator
um what aspects of research because I
know you're so curious you're so
passionate uh you'll always be a
researcher and a scholar but you know so
where is next for you specifically
um after the you know the the smash of
this book um you know it's kind of uh
after it passes by in a couple of years
yeah great question I love doing science
communication uh across media platforms
it's it's really hard for me to describe
my job when I meet new people I'm like
oh I'm a science communicator and they
say oh okay what's that and then I have
to I have to wrap battle off this list
of like a podcast a book a YouTube show
blah blah blah
um so I think I want to continue with
that I love being able to work on
different projects that I can switch
between when I get bored with one of
them
um over the pandemic I have been playing
around with a with a self-diagnosis of
ADHD and being able to jump from one
thing to another is really helpful for
my brain
but my ultimate goal is to not ultimate
my next Big Goal hopefully the book will
help with this is to
host my own TV show I'm developing one
now
have been for a couple of years because
the TV industry is really slow even
slower than publishing
um but I would love to host a science
comedy TV show I basically just want to
spend the rest of my life helping people
understand the world around them better
through science uh while also
doing my my fictional World building
thing because that is just something
that I really enjoy doing I I combine my
astronomy and my folklore expertise by
building new fictional worlds based on
science and that's that's just fun so I
I want to keep doing that yeah
yeah and it's uh they always say you
know competitions for losers you know
you should do something that you have
this unique advantage to do we already
talked about the book and this
perspective that you alone can bring
maybe these other folks that you
mentioned
um yeah I don't know if Owen could you
know and such a delightful romp you know
he may know the folklore right okay all
right but but yeah the rest of it yeah I
don't know if he has the the richness of
tone uh but you know but you're doing
something that you do have this unique
set of skills that you know like Liam
Neeson that's a very specifications
actually do not mess with Dr mcteer
um so and and you should do what
fulfills you do a podcast you do and
we'll have links all about the YouTube
and the TV is great yeah I guess the the
last question you know kind of in the
career aspect before we turn it because
I know you've got a hard break coming up
uh and I want to get to my Fantastic
Four thrilling what formerly the
thrilling three that have a fantastic
four
um uh I want to ask you you know when
you when you think about this um you
know delayed gratification in writing
this book I mean you had just started
talking uh thinking about it back in
2020 when we did our first interview you
were still a student you're thinking
about defending your thesis you're
you're still writing
um none of that's behind you
um now you're talking about TV and and
those are all so well suited how do you
handle the delay of gratification I I
think that was one of my challenges as a
student at least
um writing books whatever it takes as
long as it takes it's kind of hard to
rush it although the publishing industry
you know they're still like I don't know
about you but I was swapping the files
back and I mean it does yeah my editor
refused to use Google Docs so she was
like where you're using word and I was
like well okay uh the options were word
or overleaf so we just exchanged Word
Documents
because I don't think she would have
known how to use it
yeah I was gonna say yeah she if she
could pick up late I would I would like
to uh like to know her
um but having um you know gone through
this and now talking about TV yeah
that's even more and then it's so fickle
and it's so hard I remember writing my
first book again talking with Ryan
holiday I said you know well um he asked
yeah like he asked what's your book
competing against I said like well these
great books by Neil deGrasse Tyson and
Brian Green and Lisa Randall and he said
no you idiot it's competing against
every squirrel video there is on YouTube
right Tick-Tock I mean that was before
Tinder and all the other things I'm not
on Tinder
like
I know I've heard like I've heard all
these different like Instagram is better
for I'm like so thankful that I'm not
dating like you have no idea like
marriage cures marriage can cause a lot
of problems for some people not for me
thankfully but but it cures the the need
to go on uh I feel I feel great sympathy
for people that are searching for their
their shirt their their intended one as
we say but anyway how do you handle
delayed gratification with things like
TD it seems excruciating I did an
episode of unexplained with William
Shatner and he didn't even show up but I
I just really record it as if he's there
um yeah how do you handle that and it
took like a year to come out I know I'll
tell you when it's out it's just like
you have an IMDb PHS how do you handle
the the delayed gratification yeah I
don't handle it well I'm a very
impatient person
I I oh you can see it it's like coming
out I have been so ready for the world
to read this book for months I and I
tried to like ease some of that pressure
like like release a little bit of the
steam by going on Twitter and saying
like hey give me a random page number
and I'll show you a line from this book
like I just wanted to get it out there
um so I think using social media to give
tidbits has helped a lot but mostly it's
me um most I I have like Jaw problems
now because I'm clapping my teeth so
much because I'm too impatient
yeah the pub day is going to be huge and
I think we're going to release this on
Pub day hopefully and uh just give it
the attention that it so richly deserves
it's such a great book we're talking Dr
Moy mcteer the Milky Way and the
autobiography that our galaxy deserves
we have uh just wonderful encomium Ryan
North calls it a direct fun Charming mix
of the science the folklore and the
history yeah I love the Galaxy Kelly
weiner is that full review he then goes
on to say and because I am part of the
Galaxy like I deserve part of the credit
which I love I know yeah
they always do limit uh the the list the
list of it um how much we can actually
include but uh but yeah Paul Sutter says
make here sharp wit and sharp or
intellect strike the perfect tone for
this Breezy Tale on the history of our
galaxy truly the biggest tell-all story
in the universe and I'm so glad it comes
out in August because it is a beach read
um as I said it's it's it's lovingly
Illustrated so richly full of scientific
content it's a stealth Vector to learn
about the richest Topics in science not
just in you know some some narrow niche
of astronomy so now Dr mcteer if you
would indulge me in the main few minutes
I would like to play a game now called
the fantastic I am ready to get
fantastic
okay and to do this I'm even gonna do
something I haven't done yet let's see
if this worked computer
turn on the plug oh boom that's fancy
and I can even do this you know that
that this podcast is Into The Impossible
and I said oh one of Arthur C Clarke's
laws we're going to get to that in just
a second but the the the word podcast
that you have to podcast
um
um EXO lawyer I'm like every is it
called the everything XLR yeah uh so
we'll have a link to that uh so the word
podcast comes from Sir Arthur C Clarke
in terms of the uh 2001 the Space
Odyssey when Dave says to how open the
pod bay door so now I'm going to do that
computer open the pod bay doors
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that also I'm not
sure
good job my computer's feeling a little
bit
I'm going to turn on I'm going to plug
in my computer uh synthesize voice into
a plug that I'm going to tell it to turn
off and I'm going to see if it will kill
itself okay anyway
um Moya we have some questions here
um and the first one involves your you
talk about the Galaxy's demise we'll get
to that in just a bit but um I want to
ask you from the perspective of the
Milky Way oh okay answer these questions
so the first thing involves the what's
called an Hebrew an ethical will or a
Zava ah it's not a material giving
something to people in terms of money
um I'm sure you know Harvard and and uh
Colombia will take all of your the Milky
Ways you know munificence but I'll ask
you what wisdom would the Milky Way want
to give to Future galaxies Generations
down the line after it's after its
untimely demise
bother getting upset about
and outcome
don't bother getting upset about an
inevitable outcome
um a lot of the Milky Way's mental
health struggles come from the fact that
it is creating these Stars it falls in
love with them and then they eventually
die and it feels really bad uh that to
continue living it has to keep making
these Stars so if there is something
that you can't change that will always
be this way or or like the outcome is
inevitable don't don't get stressed
about
it
great okay the next one I want you to
um to now look into your crystal ball
billions of years more into the future
but really in harmony with Sir Arthur
Clark's famous aphorism that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic uh what is
the Milky Way most proud of that that
human beings have been able to discover
about it about the universe anything
about astrology what would the uh what
would the universe put on its monolith
so to speak in terms of a a way to have
a little bit of swagger which I know the
Milky Way has what is the most
impressive accomplishment for you for
the Milky Way to do or that it thinks
humans will do
yeah that that humans have done to make
the Milky Way proud the Milky Way will
be proud when humans find out how to do
faster than light travel that's what
it's waiting for uh it wants to see us
interact with the rest of it and like
really get to learn what it's what it's
all about and like if there are aliens
out there which the Milky Way can
neither confirm nor deny uh it wants to
see humans interact with them
ah okay uh so next question is going to
go backwards in time and it Harkens to
Sir Arthur's Third Law which states the
only way of discovering the limits of
the possible is to venture a little way
past them into the impossible that's the
origin of the name of this podcast on
the associate director of the RCC Clark
Center for human imagination at UC San
Diego so I want to ask you as a young
Galaxy uh what was mysterious about you
know there's no handbook for Galaxies
right how did the Milky Way know what to
do so what perplexed you in your early
first billion years or so that now makes
sense that you would give sort of as
advice
um to your former self or other galaxies
that are up and coming uh to try to uh
to try to you know adjust to the life in
the universe I love that so advice to
you early on the Milky Way would have
been a little confused that everyone was
going away like with the expansion of
the Universe
um it would have been like why are all
my friends leaving do they not like me
and so I think Milky Way would say to
its younger self like no it's not that
they don't like you there's just this
Force that's making them move away from
you
you're fine you're great
except for that lazy right lazy Lenny
and Sammy right there they've always
been by your side right we'll probably
have to eat them one day
okay now I'm gonna ask
oh man that'll teach them to be lazy
um I want to ask you Moya uh a
perspective now this is uh one of
Arthur's uh laws as well and he said uh
the following he said when a
distinguished but elderly scientist says
something is possible they are almost
certainly right
but when they say something is
impossible they are very probably wrong
now I want to ask you Moya as you're a
distinguished scientist
um that you know has influenced hundreds
of thousands maybe millions of people
what have you changed your mind on what
if anything have you been wrong about
that you've changed your mind on either
recently or throughout your career now
this might sound kind of meta but I feel
like I used to believe that I was a
fixed state that I was like this was my
personality this is who I am I will not
change and I have learned that I can
grow that I can change that anyone can
learn and and grow and change
um and that's that's been really
eye-opening it's helped me a lot with
the way that I interact with people and
the the way that I like judge myself and
it's helped me give myself a lot more
grace
oh that's wonderful well Dr Moya mcteer
author of this phenomenal book uh called
the Milky Way an autobiography of our
galaxy the Galaxy is for everybody I
want to thank you so much for spending
so much of your time I wish you all the
best and great congratulations on
another book and uh we look forward to
having you back as an ultra rare Third
Time guest on the into the impossible
podcast thank you I would love to come
back and thanks so much for the kind
words you said about the book it really
like warms my heart
foreign
love it and I listened to it and you all
should either get well you should get
all the copies uh digital Kindle Audible
and uh also by the hardcover which is
richly Illustrated all them are and
you'll just yes it is
kind of put on an affect like a like a
an upper class maybe type of Royal
person that's how I envisioned that the
Milky Way would talk
a bit yeah just a little bit of snark
good yeah exactly
love it all right well we love you on
the show and we wish you a great rest of
your summer great congratulations
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]
foreign
[Music]